and finally new rule be careful what you
apologize for
last week ryan reynolds and blake lively
apologize for having their wedding
eight years ago at a plantation in south
carolina
and while i'm sure we could all do
better in being aware of the presence of
racism
including in the past if this is the new
rule it's going to be hard to go to a
lot of places in the south
it was kind of one big plantation and
not just the south the stock exchange
is two blocks from new york's first
slave market
and in 1991 construction on a new
building in lower manhattan
unearthed a massive slave burial ground
from the 17th century
among the businesses that stand over
that ground today
are a dance studio and a ballet academy
so people are literally dancing on those
graves
because america america is
poltergeist we're all six degrees from
genocidal [ __ ]
if we start turning history into a big
game of guilt by association
it never ends are we really going to
make everyone apologize for standing
somewhere that
humans used to stand when they were even
more barbaric than they are now
ryan reynolds said of his wedding it's
something we'll always be deeply
unreserved and unreservedly sorry for
and it was a giant [ __ ] mistake
yeah the green lantern was a giant
[ __ ] mistake
this was you got married at a beautiful
venue you saw on pinterest
look every wedding every funeral every
slip inside on this blood-soaked land is
inappropriate
the country itself is named after a
slave trader named amerigo
but we can't just pack up our government
and pretend none of this country ever
happened
here's a crazy idea let's live in the
present
and make the future better of course
tear down statues of confederate traders
but in san francisco protesters tore
down one of grant
because grant was once gifted a slave
who he then freed okay not a perfect
score but
grant was the guy who kicked the asses
of the other statues
you've been tearing down you know while
they were alive and could fight back
a little braver i'd say there's even a
drive to remove a statue of lincoln
at the university of wisconsin because
as one student put it
i just think he did you know some good
things
but the bad things he's done definitely
outweighs them
yeah i wish i had been raised with the
kind of self-esteem
parents give their kids these days where
you can think that when it comes to
accomplishments and racial justice
you're just a little bit better than
abraham lincoln
washington and jefferson are also up for
cancellation because they owned
slaves and being a product of your time
that's not an excuse anymore but if
that's the case
if being a product of your time is no
longer an excuse
what do you have to say about this guy
and his dad he was really strict
and neither one of them had any problem
whatsoever with slavery
the confederacy used the bible to
justify their cause
because it has plenty of passages from
both testaments
to back them up slaves obey your earthly
masters
slaves be obedient to your human masters
slaves submit yourself to your masters
you see a pattern if we're going to be
consistent
i think we're going to have to cancel
god
jesus himself says at one point in the
bible
the servant who knows the master's will
and does not do what the master wants
will be beaten with many blows
thanks son of god would you let those
words slide
if it was somebody's tweet today
jesus did heal a slave once but not to
free him to get him back working
because this is how slavery was back
then they didn't see it as a problem
because no one did and if you had been
back there
you wouldn't have either you're not
better than jesus
or ulysses s grant you just came later
but i got to say that jesus you know
being god and all really should have
known better
so when he comes back to judge the
living and the dead
i say he's got a lot of explaining to do
like
hey you were always performing miracles
instead of the bar tricks with the
loaves and the wine
why didn't you zap the chains off a
slave
with all the preachings and the sermons
on mounts why not one time
throw in a little oh and this whole
people-owning other people thing
that's not right but no nada
on the subject of slavery jesus says
sweet [ __ ] it ball
so first thing when he gets back is
we're going to need an apology and i
mean a real apology
on any of this i'm sorry if my condoning
of slavery caused offense
and then i think rehab would be in order
and also sensitivity training
oh and he can forget about hosting the
oscars
you